[Music]
okay everybody i am
super excited today because i am joined
by tom hopper aka
declan smith in his newest film sas red
notice tom how you doing today man
good steve how are you doing i'm doing
really good so
this is a really exciting film i loved
it uh it's action-packed
you're jumping out of windows i'm
wondering
is this a film that you did any of your
own stunts here or is this all stuntman
kind of
pulling that way a bit of a bit of a
blend actually
uh the certainty i'm the kind of guy
that's like if they let me do it i'll do
it
um if if the if the insurance companies
tick it off i'll give it a blast um i'm
starting to do that
you know a little bit less now because
you know i've got a family i've got kids
and stuff and i think when i was a
young single book i would be like let's
do it
and then now i'm like ah now i'm gonna
go actually put my kid to bed
later today so maybe i won't do that um
so you know as you get older you start
to kind of educate yourself and think
actually you know what these guys are
paid to do that sometimes
but i'm still that younger buck side of
me
still can't say no so whenever i can i i
give it a blast because i just think you
get a better shot that way you know when
as long as you you know you get to do it
yourself so
i would say that a majority i like to do
but then
there was a couple of those who were
seen uh in the red noise where
they jumped out the window which they
wouldn't let me and sam do so
uh that brought him one of the big boys
but um
yeah like it's i have to say the stunt
guys on this
movie were particularly special they did
some great stuff
yeah and uh it really shows how great
the stunt work is but
again as always your acting is great and
it's interesting too switching gears a
bit you know you're
a bit of a fitness guru i wonder would
you ever take a role that required you
to get
out of shape that's so funny someone
asked me that
literally like two days ago someone said
the same thing we're on set on because
i'm shooting umbrella academy season
three
and we were talking about that and then
someone was like tom would you and i was
like
i don't know man like health health and
my uh
life outside of acting is you know and
the health of myself and my family you
know is like number one it's paramount
but
i think if the right role came along
and i could do it in the healthiest way
possible so i wasn't just
junking down pizza and stuff i was
actually eating
some clean calories to get like bigger
maybe
um but you know prosthetics are good
these days man
i mean but then you don't get the
respect
that people want to see you change so
you know i think if it was a
life-changing role and like uh something
that i thought you know what i have to
play this role
maybe the life the life life and times
of john candy
[Laughter]
i do i do that role really that that
sounds
that would do it um yeah so before i let
you go
six weeks ago on instagram you won a
record saying that back to the future
two is your favorite film
can you tell us why and would you play
biff in a reboot oh my god yes
my only worry would be i won't be able
to do him justice
but oh no you'd kill it i have all the
characters yeah this would be the one
that i would
100 want to do because he
biff plays so many different types of
himself
so the biff in 85 when he's like when
he's running the
the car ballots in service compared to
the other bit in 85
and then obviously the biff in uh back
to the future two where he's
got all the money like and then
obviously you've got um
mad dog tannen in in in the third one so
he's got this broad spectrum of the
types of character of that one
version it's brilliant so and griff as
well in in
two it's so good so
but the reason i love two is like it's
probably my
favorite sequel one of my favorite
sequels i think judgment day terminator
2 judgment day is up there as well but
um a it was
back to the future was made the year i
was born um
so that was one more factor but i love
the future
i love the future in back to the future
too it's the future that i
looked as a kid and went oh my god one
day
2015 is going to be like that
and i really truly believed it and
wanted it you know yeah
um and the hoverboards the flying cars
is the future that i was like
that would be so cool and i used to
watch back to the future too like all of
my
the whole saga watch over and over again
but back to the future too
man i watched that thing time and time
and time again
loved it no i love that you praised that
and it's really exciting for tom hopper
die hards to hear
that he will play biff universal if
you're listening you have your biff and
your reboot
you got your best baby you got your back
bring it wreck that down
and while we have tom hopper here he's
gonna be
sas red notice it's on demand tuesday
make sure to check it out
tom thank you so much for joining me
today and i hope to talk to you again in
the future
thanks so much steve been a pleasure